we have Paulo Coelho also one of the
organizers of the boot camp
speaking about sums of squares we're
gonna two lectures this afternoon and
then we'll come back tomorrow
oh yeah if you have questions you can
tweet I hope I'm saying this correctly
anyway two or three things I guess
before I start one of the stated goals
that we got from Alistair is that were
supposed to bore the experts know if we
don't bore the experts we haven't
achieved our goal so you know I I fully
intend to do so the second part is I'm
going to actually use a board I don't
have slides or ATM prepare slides for
this but there's a whole bunch of slides
I'll post links I mean we have a lot of
material related to these kind of things
so if you want to actually see
everything in full detail you'll
certainly find links over the other
thing is no an organ of I'm doing these
lectures with an takuna question here
today he'll be here
I think on Wednesday he promised that
he'll watch this talk I actually don't
trust it no you know what he will
actually watch it so I'll just write
something in here but you know get
enough and if he's watching it then I
expect him to mention it I'm just
writing it Ward you know can no one I'll
erase it later I just want to see
whether so nobody asked him about it
okay just a little test and I want to
run again okay so we won't talk a little
bit about some obscure stuff so let me
first just start mentioning some things
about America drumming Michelle gave us
a very nice introduction I just want to
remind you a couple of things that he
said and I'm going to also emphasize a
couple of different things
mostly because I related to the kind of
things that we that we talked about so
he'll really find this very nice form of
I also I want to use some particular
notation that I'm going to use so can I
find this a very nice primal-dual form
of what is my definite programming looks
like I'll define my notation in just a
second but the idea let me write exactly
the same thing that he brought he said
we want to have a variable X where X is
a symmetric matrix this finally
expression I'm using in here is an inner
product between matrices a trace of the
product so in here I really mean a
linear functional on X 1 X is a
symmetric matrix I have affine
constraints a sub I of X equal to B sub
I and I have the positivity constraint
xv+ see later right and I know you know
of course algebra is beautiful but
geometry is even nicer so what is the
geometry of a semi definite problem at
least Larry know kind of the simplest
things that you can drive in here it's
really when you look at the feasible set
is about the intersection of the cone of
positive semi-definite matrices right
that's what this mean it's a very nice
complex cone the cone of all symmetric
matrices which are possibly my definite
and some affine subspace which I like to
call L and this is going to be my
offering sub special order so really
semi definite promise the problem of
intersecting a nice convex cone with
another in subspace and then you
optimize a linear function over this
intersection by the way if you like
linear programming linear programming is
exactly the same picture except that
this cone is a polyhedral cone is a
non-negative orphan but it's a really
difference between linear programming
and Sumerian perming so do we go from
the non negative or from the polyhedral
cone doing non polyhedral cone which is
a cone of possible symmetric matrices so
the other beautiful thing about that
we've seen in in
Shell's lecture about semi-definite
programming like any conic problem is
that comes with a nice dual let me write
me here and erase it later which has a
four max of V transpose Y subject to the
condition that the sum of a so by y so Y
is less than or equal dancing so as a
reminder he draw lead in the abstract
form or the write and operator and the
adjoint so in here if my operator is a
one that takes a matrix into the vector
of the AC wise inner product of the X
the adjoint of this is exactly the sum
of the AC wise Y so by right showing
here
if you want we have a map that takes X
into a One X a X so they are doing of
this in your map is something that goes
from RN to symmetric matrices and that's
exactly this map over here so I'm just
writing exactly they do what running
coordinate one right he gave us the
option Persian so semi definite
programming again and again of course
the geometric picture is exactly the
same in here what we have is
intersection of the corner positive
semi-definite is just take this to the
other side and we're intersecting this
with samatha in subspace so
geometrically big things will be exactly
the same on the primeknit one what are
some of the properties again I'm just
restating what mission said of course we
have weak duality
what does weak duality say it say that
any feasible solution of the primal the
cost of any feasible solution of the
primal is always going to be below the
cost of any feasible solution of the
dual or essentially that if y and X are
primal and dual feasible then see X is
going to be less than or equal than B
transpose Y for any feasible for any
primal feasible X and for any dual
feasible Y and of course inequalities
along way right so we do all T always
hold and and the argument the reason for
this is really this one line argument
that Michelle row before I'm not going
to repeat
also and the weak conditions and the
minimal conditions really we also have
strong duality and the value of the
primal is exactly same as value of the
dual and I'm not going to
and I know for the purpose of this talk
let us say too much about learning can
afford these conditions are I think what
what Michelle said is perfectly well
somehow really we have this very nice
laying out set of problems and one of
the things you know it's kind of
surprising window semi-definite Boeing
has been around for twenty years or so
he said we still don't understand it now
you know we still really don't
understand what's going on here
we don't really understand this
expressive power and I think it will
become clear that what I mean by this so
let me give perhaps a couple of examples
if you've never seen a semi definite
program in which way they differ from
what a linear program alright let me
just write a couple of examples perhaps
I guess if you've never seen this I
guess this picture kind of a clarify a
little perhaps the simplest way of
stating the difference is the linear
program in case is of course a feasible
setting here is not necessarily going to
be polyhedron right now you know so let
me give a concrete example or we'll say
this so let me write the particularly
nice my example one a particularly nice
a my the same problem that it's going to
be something like this so what do I mean
let me not write the cost function I
don't care about the cost function the
cost function is just some linear
function over this set so what am i
doing in here I'm putting it make it
positive semi-definite matrix that
depends linearly on x and y so it's
really something I guess in the way I
wrote it like in the dual form right so
what's my feasible set in here it's
going to be the set of X's and Y's that
make this matrix positive semi definite
and I know enough we need to decide or
how do we plot this right I mean we need
to find out what this set is it turns
out I mean you can do these things by
hand you can do this in Mathematica
maple whatever but what happens in this
case is something very nice I know the
feasible set is essentially something
that looks like this it's of course a
convex set and this convex set is going
to be something over here in there in
fact how do we draw even this picture so
certainly the boundary of my set is
going to be given by one determinant of
this
vanish that's exactly when these
matrices stopped being positive
semi-definite if we write that down it's
going to be an equation that will look
like this and this is of course the
simplest case of an elliptic curve right
so the feasible setting here is exactly
determined by an elliptic curve I mean
exactly this polynomial equation x and y
and the feasible set corresponds was
called The Oval of the elliptic curve
this correspond to this nice convex
region in here why do I know this for a
couple I want to illustrate a couple of
things on the one hand as I promised and
it's obvious the feasible set of semi
definite problems is not a polyhedral
set in general but also to mention one
other thing that's very important for
many things that we want to do later
which is that when you think about the
convex set that comes from semi definite
and really think of the boundary of the
set that boundary comes with a lot of
baggage on it in this case it comes with
all these other components that are
outside my convex set and those actually
play a very important role in
understanding what you can and cannot
describe using some may be a product for
polyhedra this is not terribly
interesting this one you have a
polyhedra then somehow you extend the
facets and you get a hyperplane
arrangement and some so you get this
arrangement of hyper planes which are
all the inequalities and that's
interesting but it's not terribly
interesting I mean that's it's a very
interesting area fiber beam arrangements
but now you know can have a lot more
happens when these things have not
necessarily for here questions
clear good so let me describe another
example may example two and I guess I
should mention this is perhaps one of
the simplest examples of hyperbolic
polynomials this polynomial is actually
a hyperbolic polynomial if you want to
understand the geometry of these curves
and lots of things we can accent here
one of the experts and this yeah so I'm
dumping if you're on you let me give my
second example which is again something
I think many of your products emit so
perhaps in here I should write when I
can elliptic careful
so my second example is something that I
think many of you know in particular at
least two or three people in the
audience which is
and of this nuclear norm stuff so what
say being here let me just say find a
function so I have a matrix M and let me
define this function which is just the
sum of the singular values of my matrix
L so remember whenever we have a matrix
a rectangular matrix it it doesn't have
to be symmetric or anything even squirt
we can look at the singular value
decomposition you Sigma V transpose what
U and V are orthogonal matrices and
Sigma is al on the Lord as the unless it
could be given its rectangular and we
can define this quantity called the sum
of a singular value so that so in
general it's hello I mean it's a nice
but somewhat complicated function of n
but it turns out that there's a very
nice description of this in terms of
semi definite let me write explicitly
something like I know this quantity it's
actually the minimum of the trace or 1/2
times the trace of U plus a trace of be
subject to the condition that my matrix
U and M transpose V is positive
symmetric so I claim that the following
is true it's a simple proof no no no I'm
not going to prove it in here
but that there's a very nice description
of this function this nuclear norm as a
solution of a particular semi definite
all right so given M I have to optimize
let me be very explicit over U and V in
here this matrix will have to be
positive semi definite I minimize the
trace of you and me if I find that you
and B that minimize the trace of this
function I claim that the optimal
solution is not to be Saturnus well
there is another nice example of a
function that in principle I know
there's no reason why they should be
related to some kind of semi definite
problem but there's a very nice calculus
agenda so these are just examples but I
think both of them illustrate a couple
of different things that I think they're
themes that they are kind of people have
spent quite a bit of time trying to
understand and we'll see a little bit
later in the week notice in particular a
very important difference between the
kind of things that we're doing over
here versus a kind of things that
they're doing over here in here I want
to represent a set in the space of X's
and Y's and I wrote this in my definite
program that has only x and y right in
here I want to represent the functions
or reset say that my set is a norm of M
less than or equal than 1 the unit ball
of mist norm and what's kind of
interesting in here is that this a
magnifying poem that I wrote actually
has additional variables
it has variables U and B right so what
this is an important difference is
exactly the issue of extended
formulations that we're going to see
later in the week
now you know kind of I think bizarre
Thomas and cancer I'm going to describe
a little bit this whole idea of extended
formulations and how do we work well but
geometrically the picture that you
should keep in mind it's a rather than
representing my perhaps I'm interested
in some set living directly in some RNA
and the difference that we want to
represent this set as a projection of
something else that lives upstairs
try trying here again it was enough to
write the semi definite problem only in
x and y in here i had to introduce these
new variables U and V and then write
some semi definite program in UV nm and
the projection of this on the space of
M's only is exactly said that I want yes
I thought you're saying but when I said
it will they'll talk a little bit about
this it's actually versions of these are
kind of open in different ways depending
how nice is nice and I think you guys
would probably say more about this good
questions so the set of all three by
three PSD matrices is convex so the set
of X and Y's that satisfy that PSD
constraints used to be just all vectors
all non dimensional vectors that
differently whether it gives the
matrices with some conditions like set
of entries being 0
some offering that's exactly this
picture right I mean it says if you have
a convex set then you projected yes you
always have a compact stuff on the left
[Music]
okay so they surprised the stuff on the
left
what do you mean this curve oh just look
at the co set of this equation right so
when I look at the equation that defines
the boundary of this set the equation
that defines the boundary of the set is
is when you look at the scene or set of
this these polynomial vanishes not only
in here but vanishes also in here
they're not feasible points yeah there's
only not feasible right this is my
feasible set but my point is every
polynomial that vanishes in here would
also say let me say that way any point
in Amman that benches in the boundary
would also banished in this other
component so these will put constraints
and again we cannot talk about this
until the you know kind of the kind of
sets that can be represented using some
of these other components in there
no no they actually play an important
role so what do I want to say one of the
things I want to say now you know we
have a very intuitive understanding of
what linear problems look like we know
what the feasible set of a linear
program looks like right if I give you
my Nova Nova set you can very easily
tell me yes it's a polyhedron no this is
not a polyhedron right yes I can if I
give you a set disc and of course I have
to define how do I give it to you then
it's a we don't know how to answer this
question right now can I represent this
set using cement of a problem and it has
a lot of stuff that we know the sort of
machinery that I know with developing
around this but nothing I think our
understanding of nano spectra Hedra is
pretty primitive
I think at this point
so let me just questions it is clear
before I move on to else
okay so what is there I guess I promised
that I was going to talk about someone's
core stuff so let me start perhaps even
before when the question of why do we
care about someone scores at all and the
reason again I guess people care about
this for different reasons but one
question that very noggin of perhaps is
very natural about all this stuff is if
I give you some multivariate polynomial
so I have a polynomial P in n variables
in there let me say that it's agreed to
be I want to try to understand whether P
is non-negative I know each P of X
greater or equal than 0 for every X it's
a decision question of line or can I
give you a polynomial in several
variables and I want to try to
understand whether this polynomial is
greater or equal than 0 everything is
something that are true but you know
perhaps of not obvious first of all is
that we can answer this question at all
right so if P is actually a concrete
polynomial given by line of enough
perhaps rational coefficients it's a
non-trivial fact that there is an
algorithm that will actually answer this
question and the reason why I say it's
non-trivial miserable ok now in
principle it's not obvious at all how
you would certify such a question right
I mean in principle you could it seems
as if you got into check in all points
whether this inequality is true
remember this is not the combinatorial
situation I think many of you are used
to I know in reading here I'm really
asking the question about the reals
right for every point in a red so it's
in again somewhat non-trivial
that Lonnegan of this is decidable in
fact it's a consequence of 30 Seidenberg
that says you know something much more
general this isn't any problem what you
have 25 years and I know polynomials
over every year over the reals it's
going to be desirable and it's also of
course I guess we expected that this is
kind of in behind
there's no efficient algorithm what we
think that there's no efficient
algorithm that would allow us to answer
this question of you know as long as the
number of variables
let me just say as long as the degree is
good : 4 so what can one do about this
now you know why do we care I guess we'd
see it in in you know I guess in a few
moments or I guess many of you can
imagine that learner if you care about
optimization then trying to understand
line the simplest possible case
I know it's my a function greater or
equal than 0 it's it's kind of a
question of interest um but in here the
question is what can we do right so it's
pretty obvious like that there's a nice
sufficient condition for this which is
you know kind of be some sort condition
so if P I can actually write it in this
form then certainly this will imply that
P of X is greater or equal and see about
right that's kind of a trivial
implication and one of the things that
you know again nothing we're going to
try to understand that is in the minutes
that we have left is what can we do with
this how far can one push this condition
how powerful this condition is even
though I know in principle sounds they
know pretty much it to reality
the question is a drawing organ having
how how much mileage can one get there I
think one it's only mention also a few
aspects which are kind of interesting of
this first of all is and this is going
to be important not so much in the case
of polynomials or some other things that
one may do later but this is very nice
this is a syntactic certificate it's
purely syntactic
right in the sense that long enough it
doesn't really care about exactly what a
polynomial is no it doesn't really care
about the interpretation of the my
variables X actually the only thing that
I'm really using is a drawing all kind
of sports are non-negative right that
knocking of the square of something is
an omni is a non-negative quantity and
one of the useful things of this is that
then this whole machinery can be
generalized
whenever we have different notions of
positivity or
there's lots of notions of what does it
mean for something to be positive under
lots of ways in which I can write
polynomials in objects which are not
necessarily variables I'm going to see
perhaps a few examples of this today I
mean none course nature so right now in
the bassoonist one right and of course
people have been doing this for 200
years as soon as you write this
implication natural questions is like no
are there situations or under what
conditions is a converse comment with
you so like I said certainly people
would ask in Hilbert asked his questions
right now at the end of a hundred and
eighty hundred and seventeen years ago
right in particular line of you know
I'll mention a little bit about the you
know kind of I think the specific
question that yes but one of the things
that we can try to understand in
theories of course there's two
parameters in here the number of
variables and the degree and perhaps it
is a case that for some number of
variables and for some degrees there are
some equality in there between these
quantities so that this is indeed the
case that this is really nothing the
starting point of much of the theory but
there's some beautiful or very simple
argument that working game then
depending on the number of variables and
the degree let's try to see perhaps what
happens in here so the number of other
words I have one two three four so these
have univariate polynomials polynomials
into vada or three four degree two four
six whatever and let's try to reason a
little bit about this but again I could
just write it and I'd essentially I'm
going to write the answer but I know let
me at least convince you that two cases
in here to families of cases in here you
all know online oven we should be able
to derive on your own and so the first
one is a case of univariate polynomials
all right this column in here and I
claim I mean easy claim that if you have
a univariate polynomial that is
non-negative right so the picture is you
have your polynomial in here which is
non-negative then I claim that if it's
non-negative it is actually a sum of
course I can write in a composition this
is not very difficult to do I mean it's
the reason why this is true is because
if you have a univariate polynomial of
course I can drive as a product in terms
of the roots right and if I polynomials
actually non-negative then it shouldn't
have any real good and in particular if
it has complex roots so if it has real
roots then it must help them with even
multiplicity so from this effect is very
easy to write an explicit sum of course
a composition based on the factorization
of a polynomial let me skip the
arguments no no it's a very simple
exercise but learn if you have a
polynomial like this and all the T's are
complex they will come in complex
conjugate pairs sold I know you can pair
them up in a right way and produces
crossing opposition so that's kind of
this column no this column
non-negativity is equal to sum of
squares the other case is this first row
so this first row corresponds to
quadratic polynomials polynomials in of
the grid to or less than or equal to and
again it's not very easy to convince
yourself that the case of quadratic
polynomials really corresponds to the
case of positive semi definite matrices
right it's kind of really the same thing
a matrix being possibly my definite
means that a quadratic polynomial is
non-negative right multiplied right and
left you get exactly quadratic
polynomial and we do know that non
negative that positive semi definite
matrices have eigen value the
compositions or capture olicity
factorizations over all you want and if
you reinterpret the cheol-su
factorization on an eigenvalue
decomposition it is exactly estamos
course a composition I do not see
examples I think so this whole role is
also true and this is all again fairly
classical stuff 1800 so sense but so
here were told this other case
interestingly when you look at quality
point so let me just be very clear about
this so when you look at quality
polynomials in two variables for non
trivial reasons that I don't have time
to explain it turns out that blow in a
kind of the converse is also true when
you have it by a polynomial in two
variables and here for the experts I'm
looking at the non-homogeneous case so
I'm really looking at true
no meals in two variables of the grief
or aquatic then if it's non negative
there is going to be a samosa
composition and I know kind of one can
actually so all of this Hilbert probe he
also showed that in all these other
cases this is not true he showed in a
non constructive way that learn organ of
in all these cases there were non
negative polynomials that they're not so
much cause I'll give you an example
later but I know kind of somehow he
completely classified no I know kind of
this picture based on the number of
hours in the degree way I should say in
case right now kind of you like this
kind of things are they beautiful
beautiful beautiful generalization of
all these stuff to also a few other
cases more structure than whatever a
very nice paper by black Herman Belasco
on Smith I know that somehow they relay
these kind of things with very classical
algebraic geometric questions so we if
you want to truly understand why these
kind of things are true on in these
cases and line of and I mean that paper
itself it's it traded witness let me
also say three questions it is clear
remembering here I'm only looking at the
number of our words and the degree I'm
not looking at anything else right of
course is my polynomial has more
structure inside perhaps linear
dependence on the coefficients perhaps
and sparsity patterns whatever then I
know the answer may change but if you
really look at the whole class you just
abstract the polynomial in terms of you
know the number of hours and the degree
really these completely classifies it
something about constructive so yes it
is constructive I mean you have to solve
on human equations and whatever adidas
essentially constructed
so let me just one mention the limits on
just one thing because it's really they
seen of course when people did this
there was no real algebraic geometry
right I mean the understanding of
learning of what the solution set of
polynomial equations was like I mean I
think they know fairly I mean what's
just beginning so one of the very nice
things about this whole story said
because really the birth of real
algebraic geometry in trying to
understand in here what the exactly is a
distinction and in particular one of the
things that Hilbert does very explicitly
was a following so fine now I know again
the by no I probe that's a inverter let
me know kind of that the situation is
like this now perhaps in this case for
these cases I have a polynomial which is
greater record than 0 I know that it
cannot be the sum of squares of
polynomials but perhaps it can be the
sum of squares of rational functions
that was exactly Gilbert's question is
it true that if you have a polynomial
which is non-negative that it's going to
be a sum of squares of rational
functions and also exactly one of the
things that I guess you know I know in
1900 right now Hilbert wrote this list
of 23 problems that he presented in the
ICM the International Congress of
mathematicians in 1900 so question
number 17 was exactly about line oh is
it true that the negative polynomials
are samos course of rational functions
so now look at that wonderful statement
of what it was and lots of very nice
history and by the way if you want to
read in particular all the historical
aspects I know there's a very very nice
paper by Bruce Rasik something called
concrete aspects of Hilbert
17th problem which is really a delight
to me so questions so far
so coarse what do we want to know I mean
can we decide this question this is any
better you know sure this implies this
but the lots of conditions that will
imply that the polymer is non-negative
is this any good why do we want to try
to understand no no no it's really an
algebraic geometric reason there's no
number I mean it's not parameter
counting good so I mean there's two
questions we'll have three questions
perhaps that one would like to
understand well how powerful is is
quantity I mean oh this technique now I
know kind of unconstructive isn't I have
some other things that we can explain it
so let me at least say one thing in
terms of like no even though no you know
kind of these hooks I said like a pretty
coarse condition in order to guarantee
the non-negative it's really at the
heart of like I know much of the stuff
that we do all the time and let me just
give just one example though you know
again the one could write and people
have learn or somehow try to understand
this for a long time and mention these
connections but for instance our good
old friend Larry know kind of when you
look at the Cauchy Schwarz inequality
right and I hope I'm driving it in the
correct direction now you know kind of a
it's kind of interesting to know that
essentially for any that we can write
like a nice inequality
essentially for all in an end I'll
actually certify the cauchy-schwarz
inequality just in terms of the sample
scores of polynomials right so it's a
nice example of Lena kind of an
inequality for which you can give a very
clean
you know kind of purely algebraic proof
in here is of course in every finite
dimensional space now in Oquendo but
somehow it doesn't really require in a
sense any kind of reasoning about Lena
Lena for DX of isin and and whites of I
sorry
the other thing I should mention is that
this is really as I said this is Cauchy
short no no this is a special case of
what's called the Cauchy Riemann
identity which is kind of like a
generalization of this that will also
tell us the dyno some expressions are
naturally non-negative they actually
have some kind of nice and most cross
the compositions in fact if you think
about what this expression means these
are actually two by two minors of no
kind of a matrix that you can form with
my ex of eyes and my wife's of ice and
somehow cauchy-schwarz in a general Isis
all this stuff about scores of minors in
kind of in a way that and exactly same
thing is true for many other
inequalities I mean if you try to look
at the AGM that makes you make
inequality or they try to look at helden
inequality or many of all these
classical stuff really at heart I know
the proofs are really not or or ly no
one can give an eternity props if you
want or specific probes were really the
only thing that's going underneath is
some kind of very easy syntactic
argument of this time my name I mean
although in the sixties there was a big
logical form of a tricep to try to
understand exactly this question of
Larry know kind of what when you
reconstruct some of these probes know in
organ uh what is there what are the
axioms that you're actually using
underneath so people in logic have been
looking at the things running over the
for quite a long time
okay questions so I promise you and
again this is mostly for general culture
no in okay I promise I said that Hilbert
probe this in some kind of non
constructive way let me just give an
explicit example in here that was only
fine that was found by Motzkin actually
all the way in 1960 it's kind of
interesting this was a big jump no
energy enough between the somehow the
things that Hilbert did all the way in
nineteen hundred's apparently people
were very afraid of lying or kind of
these kind of things with the arguments
in hilbert space are not easy learn
other non constructive and whatever and
somehow it seemed like they not much of
that was intrinsic but now you can have
been a more and more examples explicit
examples were produced in particular
Motzkin gave this very nice example of a
sec stick let me just write it way to
the fourth plus one nine three square Y
square so this is it sexting polynomial
in two variables so it folds exactly in
here and kind of it's not very difficult
to convince yourself this polynomial is
non-negative so whenever you plug in a
bring and make every x and y now you
know this will actually be always a
non-negative number but it's not a sum
of squares so one part is easy liner
wise is non-negative this is really the
arithmetic geometric inequality right
applied to the numbers so this is really
a GM applied to X for y XY square and
what what what you have in here if you
divide by three it's exactly the
romantic mean of the let me see this is
a product and the cube root lion-o kind
of this is area I guess I need those
qualities
[Applause]
so this is a sum divided by three and
this is it geometrically alright so this
is certainly going to be non-negative
and I know and it turns out that one
cannot show this no kind of or that that
polynomial is not as much much and
there's many many many families of
examples that we now understand learn or
handle that for instance will fit in
here and even if you impose additional
conditions like if you want your
polynomial to be very to have whatever
additional properties for most of doors
we understand that right not miss in
some cases we can produce his counter
example and this will come back because
many of the examples for instance for
lower bounds in combinatorial
optimization things that try to prove
that some of scores cannot do better
than this or that the banker for
instance will talk about what they
really do say bootstrap many of these
examples learning okay no different
structure and essentially you embed this
problems into line over the widow the
different kinds of things that's a big I
mean what's a question at this point
knowing of anybody find this very
natural sufficient condition for non
negativity what we haven't said anything
at all is how we decide this right now
you know the end of I'm sure now you
have a sufficient condition you told me
that this is hard but I know it is
actually any easier
can we actually decide this a much worse
condition no not going to be nicer way
and they claim now you know can the hold
I'll try to show in just one second
is that this is nothing but it's semi
definite problem in this case if we look
at what's happening over there
what really have is a semi definite
programming problem so this question is
exactly reducible to a semi definite
problem and this is what I'll try to do
in the next five minutes
I'm checking them somebody please create
an account okay good
so what's the answer to it
the answer is yes the answer is every
polynomial will actually be every on-
Poornima will be a some scores of
rational functions in the second part of
the talk I'll present a much more
general version of this that will
actually imply this is a very particular
special case I should have answer why so
remember what am I trying to decide I
have P some given polynomial P I'm
trying to decide whether my polynomials
in sum of squares and remember this a
polynomial in n variables of the grid to
be and the key actually there's many
reasons I guess but let me just make one
observation which is actually fairly
important which is notice one can show I
mean it's a theorem not a very if you
will feel but is a theorem that if I
have a polynomial in here in the
inverter what's already 2d and I have a
somewhat course a composition then for
sure the degree of this polynomial skew
so Y is going to be less than or equal
in the claim the degree of my 2 so Y is
gone it enough to look at the
compositions more a degree of the device
is less than or equal to D and this may
seem like a trivial 'ti but actually
it's not true in some other situations
we'll talk about later for instance when
you look at things on the on the cube on
the hypercube then suddenly something
like this is not true if I take this
equality to mean equality model good
idea I mean model multi-linear things
we'll talk about this later
then law you know kind of in general I
may have some scores of higher degree
than this with their medical selections
but in the case that they're working
here
there's no cancellations of no
possibility of cancellations so if P has
agreed to be then the queue service will
have to be degree
so we say beer let me ask whether he'll
never let do I work out in detail an
example in just a second but maybe it's
kind of really simple it's kind of we
needed if I if P is actually the sum of
two so Y squares
I can write this kind of in the
following form I can write q1 as your
enemy game perhaps another observation
also that in here this is perhaps a
little less obvious that I can always
say straight to the case or the number
of squares in here is finite
I don't gain anything by writing
integral of quarter of squares and
furthermore I can bound a priori how
many scores appear in there we'll see
why but now I know again essentially the
number of squares is bounded by some
quantity let me actually try this and
plus the choosing so let's actually us
you actually let's just assume that this
is finite I get rolled over here so the
point is what this tells me so I can
write my PS s mo scores kind of exactly
in this form this product of this row
vector and this other vector now of
course if I have a polynomial a
polynomial is nothing but if I can pick
any basis for the span of polynomials of
degree that satisfy the degree of the Q
sub i's is less than equal than B so I
can actually write this as some matrix
let me call it L times some basis of the
space of polynomials of the realness and
equality so in particular I can pick you
know kind of all my monomials of degree
up to D and my claim is that this is
going to be of the form some matrix
times the basis of polynomials so in
here I'll write of course a transpose so
what this means is I'll have this vector
in here our sub matrix Q and I'm having
here the same factory over the edges I
should consistently use either square
brackets or curly
so again what am I saying
something very simple if you accept that
I wrote in this form then the point is
each one of this is in the span of
finitely many polynomials right the set
of polynomials of fix degree is a vector
space I can pick any basis and I can
pick the coefficient in here and then I
can rewrite this by redefining Q in this
one so my claim is a polynomial being a
sum of squares is nothing but being able
to express it as a quadratic form in
here what you is going to be possibly my
definite anning here we'll write any
basis for the space of polynomials of
degree less than or equal to D and the
beautiful part is that line on unlike
many things in life you can actually run
it backwards right so in here if you
actually have a matrix Q that satisfies
this I can just factor my matrix and
then I can produce a samos cross the
composition so if you understood this
that's right let me just work out
explicit example so you'll see that
later
it's actually very simple you think what
I'm saying what I'm doing so let me just
pick an example like this two x to the
fourth plus five Y to the fourth the
source or there are some points that I
want to make in here not just reason I'm
not sure I trust this X cube Y so it
gives a nice quality polynomial in two
variables so now you know kind of I
guess my question is whether this is
almost course or not and of course it's
kind of not obvious at all
no I know enough from this description
so what does this recipe tell me that I
should do I should this is a quadratic
polynomial in two variables so I should
pick in here some basis of the space of
polynomials in two variables of degree
less than or equal them - because my
polynomials homogeneous in here I only
need to pick homogeneous monomial
Sumerians kind of if you don't believe
me just write on monomials I just want
to simplify my life and
so I'll write this I'll write this and
again that's the point of why I do this
I mean here I'll just write a generic
matrix I don't know what the interests
of this matrix is going to be so let me
call them to see what you want until q3
q4 you're fine all right so these are
symmetric matrix either I don't write
the entries we don't have so now what
does this tell me that I have to do I
have to try to find the matrix which is
positive semi-definite and for which
this polynomial is the same as a spore
not let me make two points which are
kind of important
the first one is if these were not
monomials it is what somehow my
variables these are the HIV allottee
right this is a quadratic for if this
was a quadratic form the quadratic form
uniquely determines the matrix
representation but in here
these variables are algebraically
dependent
there's non-trivial relations between
this ccgs if you're an expert now you're
gonna be moot if I multiply this by this
I get the square of this right X square
times y square is the same thing as XY
square so that causes the effect of
these dynamic relationships that exist
between these monomials is that there's
not a unique matrix in here that
realizes is polynomial but that's
actually a whole affine subspace and why
there's a whole defined surface like I
said before this if you expand this
expression let's actually do this
whatever you want to get and get X to
the fourth times Q zero this is not the
interesting example Y to the fourth is
not interesting either times q3 but when
you look at for instance X square Y
square what happens in here is I get one
coefficient that comes from this term
and I get another contribution that
comes in here from q5
well plus whatever one or mother and so
the point is that the coefficient in
here they're always of course that there
should be linear combinations of the
entries of this matrix but this map is
not invertible in general i cannot go
uniquely learn organ from my polynomial
to my matrices so what this course is
that there's really a whole life find
sub space of matrices that represent
this polynomial or if you want
geometrically what we have what I'm
trying to decide is that either at
positive semi-definite Q that satisfies
these whole linear equations and the
geometry of this is exactly of course I
have enough ax in South space describing
the equations that this polynomial has
to be the same as this polynomial and
I'm trying to decide whether there's aq
which is positive semi-definite on these
are n sub sites so what we're doing
really in here when I write P is someone
scores what I'm really driving
underneath is some nice semi definite
product let me remove their word nice
depending on yes how close and Merricks
you are or what the exactly you wanted
oh you know but certainly let me knock
it away someone's conditions exactly
really some kind of semi definite
probably in this case right so for this
example in particular you can easily
verify that the matrix so for instance
if you look at this matrix 2 minus 3 1
minus 3 5 0 1 0 5 so this matrix is
positive semi definite and if you take
this matrix plugging in here and expand
this then you'll get your polynomial but
and furthermore this matrix is positive
semi definite because it's of a form L
transpose L what L is a matrix 1 of
square root of 2 2 minus 3 1 0 1 3
andrey anokhin the from here we can
explicitly write down that my polynomial
is a sum of squares because it's going
to be 2 x squared plus 3 y square
plus XY squared plus 1/2 I know Y square
plus 3xy if I did everything correctly
- here yes thank you so I go if Macaulay
what I need to compute this it's matrix
Q so in here what I'm the only thing I'm
claiming and one can fill in all the
details is that what I'm doing is a
saying the B's question it's exactly
reducible to a semi definite for me
question we Michelle skip these two now
you know if you really want to talk
about the complexity aspects of like
know what exactly is complexity of
simulated bombing then let me know if
you're opening a little bit we can and
it's not really kind of ones I mean you
just have to take care of a whole bunch
of things but mostly laying or most of
the time we talk about the approximate
question right you talk approximate
feasibility of a semi definite product
now you know kind of all that's the
other thing if you can guarantee there's
an interior point and you're perfectly
fine but if you guarantee that line okay
enough there's an interior that the it's
my life in problem actually has an
interior of solution then you get full
Parliament I'm sorry because you don't
have in here this kind of bad behavior
that can happen in some other things
so let me also mention one thing most of
the time we never care about the queue
service when you talk about the Samos
core certificate or what you never
actually compute the queue service in
the sense of learning or the end up in
here these polynomials are not really
the important thing the important thing
is this is it positive semi-definite
matrix that actually certifies that your
polynomial is accessible squash this in
particular the factorization is far from
being unique right now I know he loved
those many ways of factorizing matrix
but Larry knocking of this again this is
sorts of non unique essentially for any
point in here you have a difference and
of course representation but the point
is that you know somehow this it's a lot
easier to write a lot more natural to
probe properties about this object
rather than the DF service in general we
don't care I saw you take you suffice in
general we don't care about questions
right let me mention to the delay so I
wasn't sure wanna throw this in but
there was a question that I missed out
from the internet some squares so
essentially what you use so by the way
Horwitz did this no no I know what you
write is X 1 to the 2 D plus X 2 D to
the to D minus 2 V X 1 X 2 V this is
actually some escorting some trivial but
very no good enough this is actually
it's a much worse than essentially from
this you practice and know this
interesting point
why doesn't actually contradict what I
was saying before no I know kind of in
terms missing here the inequality that
you probe is actually the number of
variables is equal to the degree this
actually makes a difference no kind of
yeah again yeah yeah if you look at
Bruce Resnick papers I know he talks
quite a bit about this just one can
actually use is a succeeding as a way of
producing examples of polynomials which
are non-negative let me give two answers
to this I know one is the reese like in
every semi definite problem there is
economical answer no in okay no that
comes from if you want the maximum
entropy solution or low enough one that
maximizes the determinant of this I'm
going can't ride it and it has some nice
properties so for instance in a
univariate case a property that this
matrix will have is that the inverse is
Hanken right line I can find you look at
this but you know well you know that
essentially the optimality conditions
the inverse is going to be huncle and
that's actually good for some other
things and kind of nice in the interior
of the cell model or some other things
like now sometimes we want to do
something simpler right you want to say
okay let me try to avoid solving semi
definite problem and let me try to just
write the matrix based only on the
coefficient no no no under different
candidates in particular there's a very
nice natural candidate to just that
respects if you want the invariants of
the problem online okay so of course and
the issue is
how do you show that the positivity
coalition thoughts and like and uh
that's a little bit what goes on in some
of the things I guess I'm foot will talk
about on Tuesday some of this and when
you look at the analysis of random
problems you don't want to actually
solve this in my definite problem so
essentially you rely on some recipe
knowing or can the one then the whole
game is to prove that that recipe
actually has the the positivity
conditions that you want and if you kind
of impose enough structural constraints
on what you like that condition to be
and I know there's some natural gases
[Music]
like everything best depends on what do
you want coming
so for combinatorial problems monomials
are fine yeah sorry so the question is
you know kind of what is the best basis
I saving here which is something that is
true but like everything that I said of
course but you know that in here you can
pick any basis of the space of
polynomials but of course they have
different stability depending on what
you want to do I mean some may be better
or worse from the numerical point of
view there's strong reasons why if you
have some understanding of your set say
you're doing things on the cube or the
sphere then I know you would like to
pick in here a familiar orthogonal
polynomials in polynomials with some
kind of ortho on ality property
underneath they have good numerical
properties some other cases like in the
combinatorial case and I'll talk perhaps
a bit more about this there's some nice
there are some reasons for picking bases
with some combinatorial interpretation
and I know I'll give at least two
examples of that later it's a really
depends on whether you care about the
pneumatics of it or do you care about
analytic work and I know kind of doing
things on paper on paper any basis will
be fine quite often is very nice and
very simple to work with monomials or
scale monomials or something like this
but numerically particularly if you're
working in RN Newman monomials are
horrible basis by the recession
they're very nearly orthogonal if you
try to learn others essentially no
difference numerically between X 300 and
makes you
right they're kind of the same thing
numerically so you really want to work
with some powerful and polynomials use
those a lot better okay so in the five
minutes I have left let me at least
mention and I'll continue I guess after
a break
but how do we take this very simple
question about a fixed polynomial right
so far the only thing that I've told you
is I have a fixed polynomial can I
decide yes or no
what are these polynomials it's almost
quarter so you know I saw the same idea
in problem if it's feasible great if
it's an infeasible no it doesn't work so
what I want to try to understand is how
this is really the piece for the line
okay not really a centerpiece of a much
larger machinery that you'd allow us to
understand not just what happens for a
single polynomial but really understand
line of kind of systems of parlament
equations in general and let me for that
dino kind of again i'll talk about the
general version after the break
but let me talk about the very very
simple case first which is what would be
like what would happen if what I want to
do is to minimize my polynomial P or
attempting to minimize some polynomial P
when I claim that mimicing P is really
kind of the same thing of trying to
understand if P is greater recording for
what values of gamma so again picture
this is my polynomial okay this is not
quite a polynomial you know kind of
there's some value gamma and I what if I
want to find a minimum then perhaps
that's equivalent to finally the best
lower bound that I can finding the best
lower bound is of course finding the
best gamma for which P of X is real or
equal and gamma for all X this is
difficult essentially non negativity but
something that implies is if you find
the largest gamma such as P of x minus
gamma s mo scores and I claim that all
the machinery that I told you about that
somehow before was about deciding
whether a single polynomial is amosmoss
or not somehow extend to this
in particular but also to more
complicated situations are the
coefficients of P depend are finally on
some decision variables so let me
highlight what I mean let's imagine that
this is actually the case that I want
now I want to try to understand what the
largest gamma for which P of x minus
gamma is a sum of squares the same thing
just because my polynomial in here is
not homogeneous and I don't want to
change it let me assume that what
depends on gamma in here is not the
constant term like in here but let me
imagine that my gamma appears in here so
I have a polynomial whose coefficients
depend linearly on some parameters
perhaps a single parameter like again
perhaps many I don't care and then claim
that the addition of this parameter or
this line of many parameters doesn't
change a picture at all why this what
did I do in here I wrote some quadratic
form in here or some matrix and then I
wrote linear equations that would say
that the coefficients of this were going
to be equal to the coefficients of this
so now if I put linear dependence on
some parameters in that the only thing
that changes said before I was saying
that this was equal to minus 1 and now I
can just say that this is equal to minus
gamma so now what I'm going to have is
linear equations between the entries of
Q and some decision variables that I
added but still is exactly the same
picture what are the constraints that I
have I have something that has to be
possibly my definite and I have some
linear equations that need to be
satisfied and this is going to be
crucial this really the important thing
about the ones course is not that I can
decide for a single polynomial where it
is a motion not but it's really if you
have enough in subspace of polynomials I
have enough finally parameterize subs
family of polynomials in here when you I
have a gamma and here I can write 2 plus
beta in here I can write line on the end
of 2 plus 5 gamma whatever
Delta and I'm trying to find line of
values of these parameters in such a way
that this polynomial is sum of squares
it's a nice semi definite program
underneath in exactly the way that I
described it before and this is going to
be very crucial for many things but in
particular for all these hierarchy
business writing we'll see exactly how
happen this is probably good time to
stop questions do it sorry so I'm not
saying anything at all about big
complexity again because if you want to
talk about even for semi definite
programming no you know kind of somehow
you have to really look at the structure
of polynomials look at the particular
structure of the polynomials that you
care about so for instance learning okay
I mean I guess we know this it does it's
very simple to write the you know kind
of every semi definite problem is sum of
squares thing in this class
right so somehow without answering the
full question in the semi definite
programming case for all polynomials and
learning of enough this is not I mean
this is a more general case of that for
particular situations when you restrict
for instance you know your polynomials
you have a particular form of this of
that then not even if there are results
of this type
[Applause]
all right no worries we're gonna come
back in half an hour right now we have a
bridge and we'll have
[Applause]